hello everybody and welcome to another
python basics tutorial video in this
video i'm actually just going to answer
a couple of questions that i see people
ask quite often and the first one is
going to be the shebang line uh that's
this line you'll see pound sign
exclamation mark us
r
uh and then something like bin python
now
if you're on windows this is really
useless but you'll still see it on
people's
modules sometimes or maybe on some
example code and you might not actually
know what that means
and this is referred to this as the
shebang line and basically what it's
going to do is
if you're on linux it notifies linux of
the path to python so you can actually
run this script as an executable
but on windows again it's there's really
no use for it here you could use this on
windows and still tell windows sort of
but it doesn't work the same
but anyway that is why you are going to
see something very similar to this quite
often in scripts people just put them up
there now the next thing that you're
going to see quite often in scripts and
especially modules is the following
so
on people's modules
a lot of times you're going to see the
following so uh let's say you've got
this module that you've downloaded and
this module is epic
and what epic does is just print
wow this is great
right and then in on the module itself
um maybe or the script that someone
wrote but it's for the purposes of a
module
um
you'll see something like
uh
if
name
equals
main
print
that okay so you see something like this
um and so we'll run this script
and you'll see it says such great module
okay
and the question that people ask is why
do people write this why are people
saying if name equals main
well the reason why people say if name
equals main then run this stuff is so
people can use this code as a module now
let me show you so now
in your script
for example my script is called
um
epic thing dot pi
now
in that same directory that you have
epic thing dot pi
make another example uh like another
script okay
so let me uh bring my folder over here
there's epic thing.pi let's go ahead and
copy and paste epic thing.pie another
script
and we'll just call that
another script we're very
fancy in our name calling and we'll open
it with idle
and again this was just a copy of
epicthing.pi so it's got the same code
but let's say instead you wanted to
import epicthing.pi
you want to say import epic
thing
like so that's how you can import
another script now epicthing.pi has a
function called epic so what we could do
in our script is we could do epic
oops
epic thing dot epic
okay save that and we can run this
and we get wow this is great okay so
we're treating this like a module
like i had mentioned before that you can
do so
enjoy now the reason why it says if name
equals main is the following
if
uh we go to epic thing.pi right the
module that we're importing and we get
rid of if name equals main and we bring
print over
and we say
we run epic thing.pi
and we get the same outcome that we had
before it does such great module
um but what ends up happening
is if we come into to our other script
that's importing epic thing and then all
we wanted to do was just do epic
thing.epic
but instead what do we get well we get
such great module and then wow this is
great why do we get that well the reason
why we get that is that the instant that
we imported epic thing we run epic thing
kind of like it basically what happens
is when you import the module it's going
to run through that module to load it in
just like it
python would load
your functions and it loads things in
order so
in the order that it got it it imported
epic thing it stores the function and
then it's going to go ahead and print
such great module so that's why we use
if name equals main
that will stop that from occurring okay
so we do it again and we don't get that
now why does that stop that from
occurring well if underscore name equals
main basically what it's asking is is
this the main
file that's being run so basically it
asks are we actually running epic
thing.pi or are we running some other
file so as long as we're running some
other file it's okay
and if we are running some of the other
file this will
return a false
and this won't run
and so that's why people use if name
equals main
hopefully that was informative for some
of you guys if you have any questions or
comments feel free to leave them below
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time